if freedom is only reduced to I must be
able you know to wear my guns and then
you don't understand what freedom is
then you then you never read Spinoza and
some other great minds who explained
that the essence of freedom is that if
we want to become truly free human
beings that means that we can get rid of
stupidity prejudices hatred also of fear
and and and and that we can acquire a
certain truth and that exactly in this
freedom we will find the secret of our
own human dignity again if we do not
know what the true meaning of the word
freedom is if we do not know what a true
meaning of the word democracy is you're
lost if I may go back to my a great
fellow Dutchman Spinoza who lived in the
16th century who escaped from a kind of
fundamentalist background because
quote-unquote he wanted to live in truth
and as I said he wanted to find out he
realized with so much I mean he was he
grew up in a business family and he
realized I mean so many things are
absolutely trivial not really you know
worthwhile so what to do with how to
find real things and so he started to
think about it and he discovered that
yes there must be something that like
truth and and and wisdom and he wanted
to devote his life to it and he also
realized that there is this
quintessential connection between
freedom truth human dignity which you
can define as a friend of mine once
we'll set our home coming to our better
self we all have a double nature we are
human being so yes we have this
animal-like instinct where Freud wrote
about our sex aggression death instinct
but we also know we can know
about four trophies and what beauteous
there was pieces about how many is it's
also so if we want to acquire those
values have become an incarnation of an
embodiment of what we should be that's
the true human dignity that is what
George Steiner said our homecoming to
our better self and then Spinoza
realizes that you can only do this in
the setting of a democracy that's to say
we need political freedom we need a
situation where is a plurality because
if and if there is an absolute truth
nobody can claim it I mean that's the
whole thing they fundamentalist every
fundamentalist whether it's a secular or
religious Islamic Jewish Christian
whatever claims for himself and the rest
of the world I know what the truth is
the interesting thing is that something
can only be absolute when it's
transcendental when it's beyond time
being death the case no human being can
claim this is you know I'm in the
possession of spin also realized it so
so Spinoza realized okay we cannot we
should never give up the idea that R is
truth and that R is an absolute truth
but there are many ways to approach it
which means they have to be plurality in
which this can only be the case if we
live in a true democracy now but it's
true democracy and this is already a
things to greet this conference you can
only have it when you dealing with
educated more or less rational thinking
independent human beings which is a
whole series of words for one simple
thing true liberal education without
true liberal education you can never
ever have a true democracy because we've
altered
this is Nietzsche Dostoevsky Ortega y
Gasset
you will get the mass democracy and in
the mass democracy is a source is a
society deprived of spiritual values and
it's open space for mr. limb back or
ruslan back or
the demo Cox and populist this mr. dope
at at CN and I mean dangerous dangerous
people we have seen it in Europe all too
well mr. Goebbels know everything about
propaganda and a networked propaganda
always works in a society we have
deprived people from the rational factor
to be educated to think for themselves
and to be related to to to serve the
spiritual failures so a mass society we
know from European history is the first
step to a totalitarian society and again
Plato already knew that a democracy has
a nice capacity to commit suicide in
Europe had happened twice and there is
no guarantee whatsoever that it will not
happen a third time there is also no
guarantee whatsoever that death cannot
happen in America of course it can
happen as well
you